[Music]
thanks for joining us we are here today
with Garry wills the author of bomb
power the modern presidency and the
national security state along with about
41 other books over the last 50 years by
my count and I just wanted to start off
with this rather chilling quote that you
use right at the very beginning of your
book from Vice President Cheney who's
describing presidential power Cheney
style and he talks about the president's
power to launch a nuclear war and he
says the president doesn't have to check
with anybody he doesn't have to call the
Congress he doesn't have to check with
the courts explain why you chose that
quote to frame this amazing book was
he's quite right of course and saying
that that power does rest in the
president and was given to President
Truman right after World War two
the argument then was we're in such a
new era of atomic warfare that if we
were attacked or there was an impending
attack attack or a threatened attack
there's no time to talk to anybody to
consult Congress to get a declaration of
war the president alone has to make a
decision right like that and either
anticipate or retaliate and so at that
moment unusual in our history world
unique in our history he was given sole
power over the launching of a nuclear
attack consider that that's an
extraordinary thing into the world could
be hit the end of course Cheney thought
that was the basis of all later
presidential power and he had a good
reason to think that in the Reagan
administration people argued in the
White House that that kind of instant
retaliation is still necessary that if
the government was were decapitated the
president the vice president were killed
you can't rely on constitutional
succession and get the Speaker of the
House because a year and down the road
he or she doesn't know
the mechanical technical things about
how to respond to a nuclear attack so
they began an exercise rumsfeld and
cheney and other white house staffers
we're told to go off in the middle of
the night to an undisclosed location the
beginning of that term and they planned
a nuclear retaliation with their
advisors and their technicians they went
through that whole drill they were still
practicing it in the 60s now what's
interesting is that Cheney did it in the
terrorism attack he was in the White
House and September 11th II mean he was
in the White House and he was told there
were planes not just one plane but
planes going on to make further attacks
and he said we don't have time to ask
president he's flying somewhere around
in the world we have to respond
instantly Scooter Libby standing at his
elbow said he hesitated just that
split-second that a batter hesitates
before hitting the ball and he ordered
shooting down the planes thought there
were planes the one and so the the Jets
scrambled but the one went down in
Kansas before they could shoot it down
but anyway he was doing what he had
planned and practiced to do in the 1960s
outside the military chain of command as
the 9/11 report showed outside
presidential succession now because of
bomb power the president has this sole
power over the bomb even though this was
not a nuclear attack Cheney equated it
with a nuclear attack which is not
unusual it started really started with
the Korean War Secretary of State Dean
Acheson said to Truman then well this is
not a nuclear war but we have to protect
your brand-new absolute power over
starting war without Congress so don't
ask for a declaration of war from
Congress don't even ask them for
permission or approval or anything and
Truman didn't and since that time we've
had no congressional declaration of war
in all the postwar post-world War two
period so you're describing as since
this unbroken ascent of centralized
presidential power you're arguing driven
by the existence of the bomb and the
power of the President to use that bomb
but when Cheney says the president
doesn't have to check with anybody isn't
he being somewhat a historical in the
sense that presidents many presidents
have checked with a lot of people over
the decades of the existence of the bomb
and and Congress has agreed to
deployments and funded them and there's
been something of a some shared
responsibility for the bomb would you
agree well some shared but you know as
in the War Powers Act but Congress has
no authority to share its power the
Congress the Constitution says Congress
shall have power to declare war and it
only because the presidents were
declaring war on their own Congress
finally said well let's get a little bit
into the act so they passed the
so-called War Powers Act in which the
president is supposed to notify them
when he goes to war and has a certain
period date certain to come back to them
and say should I continue this or no do
you want me to stop they have never done
that second step never so that was not
very effective obviously no emotion even
a stronger argument in your book you say
that Congress actually by passing this
resolution that would require
congressional action before going to war
Congress was giving away pal oh yeah
it had no right to do it right and yet
Dick Cheney sees that resolution as the
ultimate symbol of the restraints on
power of the Lilliputians pulling that's
right for four decades he was adamant
and saying we've got to repeal that even
though it was ineffective the principle
is what mattered to him that you can't
have any infringement on the president's
freedom to act in the war area and of
course that was at Jason's point too
it's the prince
you know he could have got instant
approval from Congress for the for the
Korean War and after since said don't do
it because that'll give them an excuse
to have a say later on but isn't that
there a direct parallel in your book you
quote one of the George W Bush
administration's lawyers Jack Goldsmith
who pulled back some of those more
extreme memos from John you claiming
absolute power for the president over
detainees and I'm reminded I think
Goldsmith is the one who said you know
George W Bush could have gotten 80 to 90
percent of the powers he saw it had he
just gone to Congress brought the
Congress made a case to the public
brought the courts and provided some
limited court review he could have
gotten 80 to 90 percent but the net
result of the overreach this is
Goldsmith's term is to leave the
presidency weaker today than when he
came in well that's true of a lot of the
presidential powers the various things
that they took on had backfired over and
over and over for instance now because
of the bomb power there was the attitude
we got to have friendly governments that
we can rely on to launch and house and
protect our nuclear outposts originally
the Strategic Air Command where they can
land and refuel and all that kind of
thing then submarines then missiles and
so when President Eisenhower came in
they said Mossadegh in Iran has taken
over the government there and he won't
be very friendly to us because he's not
very friendly to the British taking away
their oil rights so we've got to topple
him and Eisenhower said okay until the
CIA to knock off that government one of
several he did that too that was a
presidential power but what has been a
result ever since Iran has been a
hornet's nest of trouble for us because
we took the Shah we put the Shah back
and they overthrew him and hated him and
hate us ever since for decades and
that's been true of many of the
presidential over
but but take that example for as one
case was that driven by bomb power or by
this larger dynamic of fear of communism
but they were spanning American Empire
taking the place of the weak British who
were sort of exiting in the Middle East
and we were filling in something eyes
now refused to do and initially in
Vietnam uh weren't your others idea
wasn't it on power driving that rather
than the fear of communism though was
always associated with bomb power but
wasn't it Soviet bomb power which is to
say it whatever lack of restrictions
there are on the United States President
you don't have to call the Congress
right at the moment of pushing the
button their way fewer restrictions on a
Soviet general secretary yeah right but
the you know first of all we had the
Strategic Air Command and we had to have
all these bases to handle them and the
the whole point was that we fear the
Russians because they can attack us with
their nuclear weapons and therefore we
have to have friendly governments to use
as response points with them and the
fear of communism after the World War
two led us to set up the NSA the NSC the
CIA the loyalty program the
classification program the clearance
program all of these secrecy's around
bomb power and all these fears of
Russian bomb power so we had to spy on
them ahead spy on ourselves to make sure
that we were not giving away thanks to
them and once you have set up that
apparatus then it has it takes on a life
of its own and spreads so that when we
have whenever we fear a friendly
government will turn against us we have
to go in and make sure that it either is
strengthened puppet government or that
we put in a puppet government and if
that doesn't work
one of the more interesting things is
that there's always a fear that the
government that the nation that we're
meddling with will turn against us and
kick us out
will they dents out yeah and so in the
60s a very smart planner ahead said
let's go somewhere where we don't have
to fear the indigenous peoples let's go
to the Indian Ocean where there's an
island called Diego Garcia it's a
British protectorate we'll make a secret
arrangement with them outside of
Congress's approval will fund it
secretly outside of Congress's
authorization will kick the natives out
will confiscate their property will kill
their livestock and then we'll declare
it off bounds to all journalists and
there it is to this day this very secret
locale that we took simply so that we
could have a safe place to launch our
war activities in the Middle East almost
a blank spot on the map yeah to use a
metaphor from old Soviet history yeah
blank spots but let me ask you in the
debates that you're part of particularly
with this book but also with a lot of
your journalism and your essay writing
and your and your other books on the
inventors of America I think that's your
phrase Lincoln as an inventor Washington
Madison Jefferson some of the CIA's
defenders draw on that history to say no
the CIA is part of a long history George
Washington had a secret fund of a
million dollars appropriated by Congress
but at his total discretion to pay spies
or more often ransom hostages from the
Barbary pirates right and so that's the
historical metaphor that for example
Lawrence Houston in 1947 when they're
setting up the CIA and he's the clever
council he says oh no we're just doing
what George Washington did that he
didn't make a reference to Leslie groves
Manhattan Project the bomb he was
drawing on that you know the father of
our country how do you respond to that
what your Washington is well first of
all you say it was secretly appropriated
but is the
procreated by Congress it's true that in
wartime shortcuts are taken
extraordinary measures are taken in an
emergency emergency powers are granted
the Constitution is suspended in part
that always happens in wartime but after
the other war times there was a return
to constitutional norms afterward and
President Washington was very good at
observing the Constitution as a
president after the Civil War when
Lincoln had suspended habeas corpus the
Supreme Court declared that
unconstitutional you know as unconcerned
understandable but is still
unconstitutional and we recognized that
but what after World War two we didn't
return to the normal because the
emergency continued and we went straight
from World War Two into the Cold War and
then into the finally into the war on
terrorism and the emergency powers that
were assumed in war were endure aided
kept protected and expanded all the
things that Leslie grosse did were
expanded into when the NSA does the NSC
does spying on us and all others and
secrecy especially was expanded so that
all of the state secret policies and the
protection of governmental power by
secrecy has just galloped ever since it
didn't slack off after World War two it
didn't slack off after the end of the
Cold War Daniel Patrick Moynihan said
there should have been a relaxation of
classifying documents there wasn't there
was an acceleration it was a gallop and
that's continued and the interesting
thing is that the the justification of
secrecy is you can't let your enemy know
what you're doing that's fine if you're
going to attack Europe you can't say
when and where d-day is going to occur
but of course after it occurs there's no
reason to keep a secret anymore
no enemy knows where you had but now we
have a situation in which most of the
time secrecy does not fool an enemy it
fools us the Congress the people one of
my favorite dooms very strips I have the
original hanging on my wall is a person
going into Cambodia and talking to a
couple there standing in front of their
ruined home bomb was a friend a friend a
terrorist yes all of the PC dragons and
he says wow this is an historic site
this is the site of the secret bombing
of Cambodia and the Cambodia man says no
it wasn't any secret I said to Martha
see there are the bombs dropping on us
the whole point was to keep it secret
from Congress not from the Cambodians
and that's been the case with most of
our secrets really to keep it from the
American people are from Congress or the
courts one of the most interesting cases
of this is Reynolds versus u.s. where an
Air Force plane went down and nobody
knew why some people survived and some
people perished
it had civilians on board doing
electronic research and the relatives of
the people who perished the civilians
who perished said we're going to sue the
Air Force because some of the survivors
said there were there was very bad
procedures on the plane so they sued
they took it to court and the Air Force
said well you want our official
investigation of that accident we can't
give it to you because it has state
secrets the first two courts said
perhaps if so show it to the judge in
camera and when if he decides in chamber
that there are state secrets then he'll
either withhold them or dismiss the suit
and they said no we won't give it even
to the judge in chamber so then it went
to the Supreme Court this was
during the Korean War with Chief Justice
Vinson and the Air Force said the same
thing and the Supreme Court said we
cannot destroy the morale of the Air
Force during wartime so we're not even
going to ask look at it in camera so
that ended it for a while then 15 years
or so later that investigation was
Declassified routinely Declassified
because people didn't realize what was
in it and the relatives looked at it now
and saw there were no sake state secrets
but there was overwhelming evidence of
criminal neglect the by the Air Force
yeah the plane was in bad trouble it had
had fires before people were not
informed on procedures for jumping out
with Helen with parachutes they were not
told the exit areas and the exit areas
were blocked so they had a very strong
case and it was taken back to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court said
oh no we still can't consider it because
Ted Olson good old Ted Olson is shows up
like Kilroy I said well there might not
have been direct evidence of state
secrets but from what was said there
might be a hint that you could look for
it somewhere else and this was called
the mosaic theory if you have one little
pebble you can reconstruct the whole
mosaic out of that one little pebble and
therefore now law thinking yeah and
therefore that case was upheld the
dismissal and that has been used as a
precedent over and over it was a blatant
lie it was just a way for to protect the
government but it's been used to protect
the government ever since well that we
have that as a constant in our
post-world War two
life there was this tremendous suspicion
on all the loyalty investigations all
the clearance investigations all the
classification things and so Moynihan
had a very good point about the Bay of
Pigs that the premise of the Bay of Pigs
was that if you put this little band of
Cubans into a bay
they will provoke a rebellion against
Fidel Castro it might have set every
academic expert every pollster who'd
done work in Cuba every journalist would
done work in Cuba said that at that
point Fidel Castro was immensely popular
man you couldn't have overthrown him he
said why didn't Kennedy pay any
attention to that because that was all
unclassified information and therefore
not important therefore not important so
when when he went to his generals in his
CIA people they said oh we have all the
secrets they don't have them and of
course that's what Lyndon Johnson said
during the Vietnam War if you knew what
I know right but you can't of course but
at the Bay of Pigs I guess some of the
recent scholarship has also suggested
that one of the reasons they went ahead
with it is they also expected if not an
uprising a successful assassination of
Castro they had the Mafia working on all
these secret plots well I would do that
so no company should do that without the
invasion though they tried right over
and over and over hundreds of times and
yeah but as well that's another example
President Kennedy said there is no when
the Cuban missiles were when the Russian
missiles were put in Cuba there is no
conceivable defensive justification for
the missiles being there so they
obviously are offensive they're there
just to attack us well there was a very
conceivable defensive reason Fidel
Castro know that they were plotting his
assassination they were sabotaging his
crops they were minding his harbors and
so he thought there was an invasion
coming and he had to protect himself the
only way I knew how after all it was not
normally in his interest to make himself
a target for nuclear war on that little
island but he went along with Khrushchev
because he knew that he thought there
was an attack coming so Kennedy lied to
the American people said there's no
conceivable of defensive reason and
Fidel knew that Khrushchev knew that but
we didn't know it but what if Keshava
just put in some of the some tactical
nukes short-range once that wouldn't
reach Atlanta wouldn't reach Washington
well we wouldn't you have you know cue
have been very well protected from a USS
Asian the Cuban pointed but didn't but
he wanted he wanted Khrushchev didn't
want to threaten us because he wanted us
to remove our Turkish missiles that were
threatening him and he also knew how far
he was behind in the nuclear arms race
there was no missile gap there was no he
was way behind so there are two motives
at work here hey and we were kept out of
both of them and so this strike goes on
over and over and over in this period
when the first Bush was thinking of the
Kuwait war he did said consult Congress
did say let's do this Admiral Crowl the
former head of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
testified before Congress would well
wait a minute there's really good reason
to prolong the sanctions for a while
just to see if they might work Secretary
of State Jim Baker came back to the same
committee the next day or right after
and said well Admiral crown no longer
has clearance to read the cables so his
opinion is not worth anything he's not
in the loop anymore right well neither
are you neither am i neither is anybody
so we all have to depend on this
priesthood of the secrets they can
they're the only ones who are qualified
to judge our fate and that's how we're
secrecy has taken us let me ask you this
you're Daniel Patrick Moynihan
would say and he wrote this in his great
book on secrecy not that secrecy was
born of the bomb power but was born from
the universal laws of bureaucratic power
and that you look around it states far
more secret than ours they don't have
the bomb and yet they've seized on
secrecy as their core tool for control
of their population of their debates etc
so how do you make that connection yeah
he quotes Marx Weber the bureaucracy
right sure that is a universal tendency
and that certainly prolonged it but what
happened after World War two is that
this was a secret on such a different
scale from anything that we invented the
NSA the NSC the CIA
these elaborate classification loyalty
tests all of those things and they were
all around the idea that the bomb is
something we have to protect and deploy
and find out what everybody else knew
about so you know some have said after
the mobilization of world war two there
would have been this kind of
concentration of power which is true but
they're just just because of the size of
the state the size of the mobilization
nodes that you know at that that often
leads after a war to a recoil into
demobilization and reconversion
as it did in england you know they they
throughout Churchill and they didn't
have the kind of secrecy explosion that
we had because they didn't have the bomb
you know they didn't have the secret to
keep so the the and you have to remember
that the Manhattan Project was an
awesome thing and it impressed the
government people afterward for a long
long time as it well should have it was
an unparalleled thing that this
concentration of talent and resources
and money was kept secret in a deetle
cals
three big ones with thousands of people
working in all of them grows general
groves in charge of it had his own
private Air Force had his spy system
abroad as well as at home spied on
Americans in and out of the project set
off an assassination guy to kill Verner
Heisenberg in German physicist and you
know this is all outside of
congressional control outside the chain
of military command very few people knew
about it even his superiors in the army
and he appointed his own successor he
said if I die if I get poisoned or
something like that there's no one else
who has all this in his head so I will
train up a band and I will appoint him
you know the Congress will have nothing
to do with it even the president will
have nothing to do with
and he'll take over from me now that was
an extraordinary thing and it worked
that was what was so fascinating and
kind of seductive that if we want to
have this kind of control maybe we have
to do what the Manhattan Project did and
that's how the president was given sole
command of the bomb the way brosé had
had and that's how all of these
ancillary forces grew up now groves
said it's not enough for me to make the
bomb I have to get it there and so he
had his own Air Force he took planes
right off the production line and had
them notified and had them in secret
bases flying with the pilots not knowing
why they were doing this
he got Tinian Island as a launch place
and he flew missions over Japan
dropping dummy bombs to make sure that
everything would work out all shrouded
in sea house nobody knew senator Truman
investigating military expenditures
never knew Vice President Truman never
knew until he became president and then
they broke the news to him you know
hello here's the bomb you're Jeanette
well we've got to take a short break and
stay with us we'll be right back
afterwards and a number of other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with Gary Wells and Tom
Blanton in just a moment
c-span 2's book TV weekend continues all
day Monday with programs devoted to
American presidents including HW brands
on FDR Jabari Aseem on President Obama
and our culture and Craig Shirley on
Ronald Reagan and this coming week book
TV is live in primetime starting Tuesday
night with contemporary authors taking
your phone calls emails and tweets for
the entire schedule go to book TV org
afterwards with Garry wills and Tom
Blanton continues welcome back we're
here talking with Garry wills the author
of bomb power and I went to return to
this exploration you've done of the
founders of America and talk to us a
little bit about how did Washington
Madison Lincoln see this role as
commander-in-chief and how did it change
since then what
what would Washington have done if he
had the bomb power well let's start with
commander-in-chief
that's an interesting term it's an
historic term it was from the British
usage and it meant that when you had
several Admirals in the same area of the
ocean and they had equal print rank the
government would say well one will be
commander-in-chief for this operation in
that theater for that time that's what
commander-in-chief meant and when
Washington went to Boston
there were militia generals and other
competing authorities and the United
States yes you'll be you'll be
commander-in-chief here so when the
Constitution was drawn up they said the
President shall be commander in chief of
the military well they met at war
because they didn't think there'd be a
standing army in peacetime just just in
war or of the states militias when
called into service by the nation
Congress would call them into the
service so he's not even the commander
in chief of the National Guard unless
Congress has nationalized the
no guard he's only the commander of the
military web but since World War two
he's become the commander in chief and
there's been a very deliberate effort to
make in that meaning of all Americans as
opposed to everybody yes
you wrote a controversial op-ed piece
right just said just pointing this out
we have very angry letters people I said
he's not my commander in chief because
I'm a civilian he's not the commander in
chief of any civilian I got letters
saying if he's not your
commander-in-chief you're not an
American get out of the country because
that now he's become that and the you
sent them a copy of the Constitution oh
that wouldn't work it hasn't worked for
many decades but that Donald Rumsfeld
said see we kept that historic usage for
a long time right up until the second
Bush administration but we had sink PAC
sink your we had commander-in-chief the
set of the Pacific European yep and so
our man over in Europe would be the
commander-in-chief of NATO forces or
whatever and Rumsfeld said no we're
going to get rid of those titles because
there should be only one
commander-in-chief and making the
president the commander chief now we
even have the acronym SCOTUS supreme
commander of the United States can you
imagine the founders coming up with that
I like POTUS I do too you know
John Adams gotten a lot of trouble for
suggesting that we should call the
president his excellency they said
that's not a Republican title well
neither is SCOTUS but now we're often
told at election time we were choosing
our commander-in-chief for choosing the
man at the button we're choosing the man
with the bomb choosing the man with the
football and you remember in the
Saturday night massacre when Nixon
wanted to get rid of Archibald Cox as
the independent counsel he had general
Haig call out the Justice Department and
say fire Cox and first person didn't
Richardson didn't then then a ruckus
house didn't and he said you have to
fire him your commander-in-chief has
given you an order
well you know Ruckelshaus is a civilian
he was not his commander-in-chief but
this aura of the commander in chief
which certainly began out of his sole
control of the bomb and then of the war
making power in Korea is such now that
we even get the president saluted when
he comes off his plane or his helicopter
saluting is something you do to the
uniform the military uniform a general
out of uniform is not saluted the
president is saluted out of uniform
now since Reagan and this interesting
thing is that you mean Nixon didn't
manage to ignite himself saluted no
really only since Reagan right and the
thing is the president is not a military
officer of any kind and that was proved
in a court case in New York his estate
parts of his landed estate that he had
in New York said well we should have a
tax break which is given to people for
military service and the court decided
well his military service you know was
long ago and he got a pension for that
but as a president he's not a military
officer at all he doesn't take military
pay he doesn't get a military pension
he can't be court-martialed he's a
civilian and the Constitution gives him
that very limited control over the
military in war they first thought and
perhaps sometimes over the National
Guard but it's a it's a unique thing
it's a civilian office over the military
but it's not a military office over the
military and that constitutional point
was really ingenious of the founders and
we were proud for a long time that we
had civilian control of the military in
our system of government because they
were deliberately setting out to prevent
monarch achill control that was that
what they were pushing against they
didn't want a man on horseback but what
about the transition between the point
of Independence and the what is now seen
as ineffectual Articles of Confederation
until finally they did create a
stronger central office unit area a
single breast was mainly stronger in the
Congress
remember Madison's objection to the
articles was not over anything about the
the executive branch it was that they
couldn't get money that the requisitions
from the states were not paid any
attention to so he wanted Congress to
have sole control over the federal money
and he said in a republic the
legislative necessarily predominates so
when they were creating strong
government they didn't think they were
creating a strong executive they were
creating a strong legislative but then
Washington himself George Washington
took some unilateral actions he stopped
sending the using the advice part of the
treaty process in that correct axis of a
dispute with the Congress no that's
that's not true what happened is this
Jay's treaty was ratified by the Senate
as it should have been and Madison who
is now in the House and drew up the
Constitution didn't like Jay's treaty
hated Hamilton's role and drawing it up
and he saw he demanded the records of
the negotiations leading up to the
treaty Washington said that's not in the
Constitution the house has no power over
the ratification of a treaty and Madison
got very angry and Washington then
released the part of the debates on the
constitution in which Madison had said
the very thing that only the Senate has
control over ratification of a treaty
and Madison really got upset at that he
said he broke trust he was not going to
release this information so he didn't
break the Constitution at all it was
Madison who was trying to mm-hmm but
speak to that secrecy over even the
Constitutional Convention which was
those records weren't ultimately
released until what twenty thirty years
later doesn't that well you know why I
mean some of the secure Kratz today I
have to say point back at that and say
see they're really good reasons for
secrecy and that's why we exist under
the Constitution of course right that
pre-existed the Constitution and it was
uh
an irregular procedure by the articles
they were breaking the articles they
recruit in effect creating treason they
were going to junk out so well dead
people look back in a row it was a
revolution it was a revolutionary act
but of course under heaven hashish
intelligence but under the Constitution
you can't say you have a right to
revolution under the settled law the
subtle ball came in now what happened is
that Madison when he went to the
Philadelphia Convention had a much
stronger government in mind he wanted to
have a federal veto on state legislation
now that would have been impossible to
pass and it would have damned the
Constitution that people knew that he
had been aiming at that and that's why
he wanted to kept secret and he told he
got Washington say take it back to Mount
Vernon and don't release it the
proceeding Jim yeah yeah because it
would it would be really damaging to him
and to the Constitution and to the whole
process and there's no record that
Washington made any solemn pledge and
when Madison was going against what he
had said there I had to as much is
always quite justifiable Washington at
that point thought he had been betrayed
by Madison on many grounds and stopped
talking to him stopped him letting him
come to Mount Vernon there was a big
break because Madison and Jefferson
sprouting had published pseudonymous
things attacking Washington which was a
really personal act of treachery and
Washington never forgave him but anyway
to use that as a some kind of precedent
for subtle bond to the Constitution
makes no sense at all and what about the
the whether it's the Louisiana Purchase
by Jefferson or maybe Louisiana not a
negative war so what what relevance does
that have uh it's just a unilateral
expression of presidential power not war
right well yeah but again this is
something he could have got the permit
if he wanted it but he thought there was
no time he wanted to have a
constitutional amendment that's what he
first proposed and his advisors said to
him we can't we won't have time to get
Napoleon to go along with this if you
have to wait if you start doing this
he'll think you're shilly-shallying but
as I say it's not war power so people
who bring that up as an example of
presidential war power are really
stretching that habeas corpus suspension
by Lincoln that's that was totally
unconstitutional in the Supreme Court
later said so now if he thought it was
necessary as a war measure we often have
war measures that are unconstitutional
detention of the Japanese during World
War two
what's interesting about the Manhattan
Project is that we had unconstitutional
procedures that got prolonged into the
into the peacetime what I even found
interesting in the history sub on the
histories that you cite like the great
Stan Norris biography of Leslie groves
he describes the secrecy practices that
Leslie grows adopted in Manhattan
Project is having been created by the
scientists themselves as a voluntary
system starting as far back as nineteen
thirty-eight thirty-nine for fear that
the Nazis might be pursuing a bomb and
so they created this the secrecy in
order precisely yeah well that was a
mutual pledge among themselves of
cooperation that didn't give him the
authority as their boss to have a fire
and they didn't and they've chafed
against that they chafed against the
censorship the all their letters were
read all their actions were spied on and
they didn't like that you know it's a
different thing but sure in the in the
fellowship of the scientists who wanted
to protect their mutual interest that's
understandable but that's hardly what
what groves was exercising yeah you know
he would he wanted to draft them he
wanted to do all kinds of things he he
threatened anybody who left the project
to that they would be drafted in the
military and sent to some remote base
and he was a total there's no crab
there's this wonderful list I think you
wrote in doing a letter to his son where
Sonny asked why all the secrecy and
Grove says well the German
number two the Japanese number three the
Russians number four the allies number
five the Congress yeah anybody else who
might interfere right yeah fascinating
and down on the list was our own staff
it's a way to control our own Stan and
he was so aware that having kept all
this from Congress and having broken
constitutional procedures so much he
would be held accountable if he didn't
win that is the rush to drop the bomb
was so great with him and with
Oppenheimer and with Truman and with his
advisors because they knew when all this
came out if they got the bomb and didn't
use it the reaction among the people
especially you know if let's say there
was an invasion and lives were lost the
people whose lives are lost would say
you had this bomb you spent all that
money all that you concentrated all that
talent drew it away from the war after
other things in the war effort and you
didn't use it it's very likely that the
president would have been impeached and
Grows would have had been
court-martialed so they felt they had to
use the bomb and you cite some evidence
in your book from the strategic bombing
survey that in fact Japan was on its way
to surrender this is a much larger
controversy and we probably want to get
into here but it was fascinating to me
because the even the decision to drop
the bomb was not seen in the moral terms
that we look at it today they had all
right long cross the barrier of mass
civilian casualties with fire bombings
and and targeting civilian centers and
so there wasn't a bright line that we
are now trying to impose back if you
will but let me just ask you this in my
reading of the various bomb and nuclear
history documents whether it's the
Kissinger and Nixon conversations or the
McNamara strategy papers the thing that
will jumps out at me is that most of
these bomb managers thought the real
problem was it was unusable that it
wasn't actually a real deterrent that
there was no way you could credibly
threaten the end of the world as we know
it and so they sought for years and
years and years other options limited
tactical nukes battlefield nukes and
then
finally the precision-guided
conventional weapons like we use today
on cruise missile that this is all been
a push by the managers who basically
didn't see the bomb is a credible weapon
well that was true especially after the
hydrogen bomb the hydrogen bomb scared
everybody you know it was called a
genocidal bomb that got unusally
destructive the atom bomb people like
Nitze you know who went and investigated
the ruins in Japan said you know they've
recovered we can use it he was not
afraid of using the atom bomb at all but
he was afraid of using the hydrogen bomb
but it's interesting that you know as
you say the moral debates that came
later didn't really occur to them for
instance we're often told well why
didn't they do a demonstration of the
power of the bomb or why didn't they
wait after the first bomb to find out if
Japan would surrender that not those
things were not really on the board as
far as a demonstration goes Oppenheimer
himself said what if it doesn't work or
what if it's not so destructive as we
think then we will have said watch this
big thing that'll show what we can do
and it'll fizzle there is always a fear
that was not going to work because after
all Trinity was a very controlled
experiment you're dropping you had the
weather control you had this little
tower in all those hey and so there was
a Oppenheimer also wanted to drop them
both on the same day the first two bombs
two different designs yeah and groves
said no you have to drop the first one
see if it works and to correct anything
that doesn't work before we drop the
second one but the idea of waiting after
the first one never occurred that they
were always going to be you both of them
are going to be used and they thought
the second one would be more powerful
and would give the idea that there's an
infinite escalation actually because of
weather conditions and all they did
where they dropped it it wasn't as
powerful as the first thing time but
anyway there was no when Truman
authorized the dropping of the bomb is
dropping at both bombs it was all
package deal
I'm cured the other great nuclear
documents that have struck me so much
recently have been the Reagan Gorbachev
discussion rivets Reykjavik and Geneva
actually it's it's just as clear and
articulated they both believe nuclear
weapons are immoral as weapons they both
agree nuclear war can't be won in any
sense of the word and they commit and
these are the folks who actually have
the bomb power both the prescient and
the soviet general secretary why would
they give up the bomb power if it's that
essential to their authority yeah well
remember when I talk about bomb power I
don't mean simply the president I mean
the whole national security state
apparatus that was set up originally
because of the bomb and that continues
even if they've gave up the use of the
bomb they wouldn't give up all of the
spy security other things that grew out
of bomb power and the in our case the
militarization of the nation the
militarization of the chief executive
that would continue even aside from the
bomb but arguably that kind of signal
particularly from Reagan and I've argued
this in some other in a new book that's
coming out gave Gorbachev a real sense
of greater security or address directly
Soviet insecurity about the American
threat and so it helped him D militarize
in fact you could argue that the
American psyche could have gone much
further in helping Gorbachev
demilitarized us and so he was able in
certain ways to turn loose of Eastern
Europe in the Berlin Wall twenty years
ago and so why isn't that you in your
book on a very pessimistic note about
the persistence of the national security
apparatus and the bomb and yet that
dynamic between Reagan and Gorbachev
suggests that there's an alternative
mode of actually addressing not only the
bomb but also the militarization of
societies well I would go with the first
part but not the second the
militarization of the society continues
and I think the purse perfect
example of that is the current
performance of President Obama you know
he came in saying well we got to get rid
of renditions and torture and military
tribunals and don't ask him to all these
other things and then he instantly
started backing off why wouldn't he do
that well a president who comes in now
finds himself with this huge security
apparatus around the world in a secret
Empire and his people come to him as CIA
people come to him and say well you know
we've got these thousands and thousands
of assets out there took them along us a
long time to build them up if you
demoralize them if you cut them loose
they'll start revealing all these
secrets you're probably going to need us
down the road why cut us off at the
knees and that's a tremendous pressure
on a president you know if you don't
play your role the whole thing is going
to crumble and you're going to crumble
with it I think that you know when you
consider that we have more contractors
in Afghanistan and Iraq than we have
military people that means we've got
this kind of uncontrollable octopus out
there and a president finds himself the
victim of his own instruments and that's
that's the long-term result of bomb our
that we set up all these instruments for
controlling the world and spying and
controlling and keeping secrets and now
it's almost impossible to dismantle and
yet even that apparatus we've seen in
waves and if you look at even statistics
on covert operations or I would argue
with you about the 1990s for example
there was a significant drop in
classification and a huge rise in
declassification under Clinton and even
under Obama today you know we have these
classic examples I even brought one this
this is a you know totally blacked out
document by President Bush almost
completely released by President Obama
on torture on enhanced interrogation
techniques to me I take the much more
positive lesson out of that that you can
actually make change that yes it's a
permanent struggle but it's not a
permanent losing battle yeah I hope
that's true on the other hand some of
the more strenuous effort to cut back
the extension of these powers the War
Powers Act the Church Committee really
didn't have much effect in the long run
you know for a while they were observed
but after the Church Committee said nuga
can't engage in all these CIA activities
Moynihan had to resign from the
Intelligence Committee because CIA Casey
at the CIA was lying to it so it's very
hard to cut back on it I hope it can be
done and various efforts had been have
had partial success but I just look at
say even though even the problem I think
that you've written so eloquently about
that the founders were facing how to
restrain power and how to set up a
government that both could deliver what
the citizens needed from government but
yet was not too powerful did not bring
back the king that that core problem
restraint on power we obviously still
face it today but if we have succeeded
in certain ways over the long term in I
would argue democratizing even
policymaking whether it's the expansion
of the vote the expansion even of the
policy debate I look at the difference
between the policy debate of the 1980s
that kept Ronald Reagan from doing more
massive massive dicks in Central America
for example didn't prevent the mass
slaughter by the domestic security
forces it was a very different
discussion than the discussion before
the Bay of Pigs or the discussion in the
United States about Iran I look at this
is almost a democratization of the
policy process that works in the other
direction from bomb power and from this
total could you not see that it's true
that iran-contra was punished but it
took place
uh so and people are still by and large
excluded from the policy discussion you
know that the the Baker Crowl example
was is we are we are still not allowed
into the inner sanctum of secrets so
it's very difficult for the citizenry to
do that now what you're talking about
about the democratization of America is
I totally agree with and have argued
about it in other ways mainly that has
been a matter of bottom-up activity for
instance never in history has a
government been so aware of human rights
as ours women's rights civil rights
black rights Native American rights gay
rights disabled rights etc that's been a
bottom up agitation and democratization
but the policy control at the top
doesn't seem to have that same dynamic
to me hmm
I just remember this wonderful quote
from HR Haldeman in response to the
Pentagon Papers and you described the
Pentagon Papers case in your book where
he says the real problem here out of all
this gobbledygook it's the end of the
idea of the infallibility of the
president yes yeah I did but to me it
says that that was in many respects the
problem with presidential power and I
just look at something like the Clinton
experience and you wrote about this
quite actively even defending Clinton in
the 1990s some very famous essays here
at his low point of his power he's able
about to be impeached he's able to drop
cruise missiles on mud huts all the way
around the other side of the world
it's extraordinary expansion but it's
not necessarily the nuclear bomb no it's
I keep saying it's bomb power doesn't
mean you actually use the box your meds
you use no it's not even a matter it's
all the consequences of the bomb which
live with us even when you're not
dropping the bomb all these things were
that were set up to protect the bomb and
deploy the bomb and spy on the bomb
those are what live on you in in another
interview mention that actually one of
your childhood friends went off to Los
Alamos oh yeah from that was a misquote
she wasn't a childhood friend she's a
current friend current free I didn't
know her back then but yeah she lived
there she grew up seven eight nine years
old this is in Michigan uh know she grew
up in Los Alamos uh-huh right uh she's a
friend of mine now at Northwestern
and of course she didn't know what was
happening I said did you know what your
father was doing he's a famous physicist
and she said no and I don't think my
mother knew but the secluded world that
she described was amazing of course she
was cut off from all her previous
friends she didn't get things like comic
books all that kind of stuff there was a
a cocoon that they lived in and they
were their big adventure
was to dig out from under one of the
there were three rings of fences and
they would dig out from one and go down
the cliff and play in a cave but they
had watch to see the patrols come by but
that's such a interesting thing to think
about that world was going on she's my
exact contemporary you know I was
growing up in Michigan and spotting
enemy planes as we was told to do and
watching all my heroes like Sherlock
Holmes fight the Nazis and she was in
this odd cocoon where she didn't know
what on earth was happening the
gatekeeper at Los Alamos had a son who
was in his teens by the time the bomb
dropped and she said to him that's our
bomb he didn't know that they what they
had been working on his tan well thank
you